yeah sri aurobindo says that
becoming is the only
being and and i think that's this is a
very interesting one
to put it is that whatever the
the the infinite is is
only becoming an infinite amount of ways
and and that that exactly could be and
this is kind of where i'm honing in on
the logic of the infinite i'm trying
again the cricket trying to imagine the
big game but i do think that the logic
of the infinite is that it must
validate the fact that it is infinite
and that it does so by creating an
infinite amount
of illusory affinity and that
we are that you know tatvam asi
we are that i and my father are one
the more that you realize and embody the
fact that if this is true
that we are the publishers of
this and the more that you realize that
we are the publishers
and the players and that here we are
playing
i think the more you live from truth the
more you live from
and when you and like you described
earlier as well
when you realize that the one eye
the one eye one i
that is experiencing it itself
from through all through all of us
and that the more that you embody that
realization if it can
you know like adi ashanti calls it you
know the flickering you know you get the
light it flickers a little you're like
oh and then and then like slowly
um it does it it is in a sense like you
said it's it's a death in a rebirth it's
a
it's a caterpillar into a butterfly if
that
light went that light and that's what it
seems like we're evolving towards
is that light permanently
staying on that's when the being
can the individual artist can no longer
ever ever have any violence
or even negativity not let yeah
violence at worst negativity at even the
most minuscule
malevolence towards another because it's
you
and then if we can get there as as a
planet
that's that's i think this this main
key of the where where we're heading
yeah i mean i and also you said if it's
true
that we are the publisher as well as the
player i would say it's definitely true
like there's no
way that we are not the same physical
stuff of the universe and
and and there's no way the the self is
what we think it is you know to
to think that you are not the main event
of
that you are not the same thing as the
kind of ground of being that illusion
kind of comes about because we take
this story we tell ourselves of
separation very very seriously right
but i think the the idea of the infinite
as well is really relevant because i
think i think they're
we've touched on it in like two
different ways i think um
and there's the first way in in the
sense that which also relates to the
idea
why i'm not i don't believe that
consciousness is the kind of crown of
being
is the only way the only kind of
speculative way i can think about
as as to why this is happening right now
like why are we why is this going on why
are we here
would be that the kind of default of
reality
if you if you have no boundaries nothing
going on like nothing to hem reality and
then it's infinity right like that's
kind of just the default
if you're going to make no assumptions
you could say there was consciousness in
the beginning but then you're like well
where did that come from what
what gave it that structure but if you
just say there's
if you say nothing effectively there's
infinity and in infinity
everything that can happen will happen
all the you know things will start
happening
patterns will emerge and at some point
those patterns become these patterns
that open their eyes and go what the
hell is
going on yes um so that's my picture of
the world is it's a lawful
unfolding that can be understood um and
there there is no
the infinity is the beginning there is
no it's not like
there was some some being with structure
who thought
i'm going to will all this into
existence i think it's just happening
and it will happen forever because yeah
you can't cut
you just you can't come up with an end
to infinity yeah it doesn't make sense
yeah um and you can also connect with
that by as
you said before like kind of sinking
into the present moment recognizing your
being now
you're the nature of your mind you know
if you say consciousness is infinite to
the
to the average person like well you know
you might be meaning it in the sense of
it is the kind of infinite ground of
being but if i say consciousness
has this quality of infinity i what i
mean is it's not finite it's not
actually
bounded into concepts in the way we
think it is we think it's divided and
structured and
but it's actually not it's it's i was
maybe it's maybe you should coin a new
term like a finite or something as
opposed to
infinite um because infinite has this
kind of i guess idea of like spatial
extension and stuff
but if it's just it's not finite um and
when you recognize that yourself you do
connect with
with this ground of being and i totally
get why you know in the best
in the kind of deepest moments of
meditation you have this
feeling of consciousness just kind of
beholding
existence and there being this wordless
getting
you just kind of you get it in a way
that you can't with words and it's
if you were going to try and put in
words is something like oh you're me
like but then that's not quite right
because there there is no me so it's
more like
it is like is or something like that
right if you if you wanted to
but wasn't it and i see why from there
because that's happening in
consciousness
it's tempting to think well maybe this
consciousness is me and this
consciousness is everything
and i think that's where metaphysically
people can kind of differ but we should
all be humble i guess
is because like i will make claims about
what we can't say and what we can say
and ultimately we're we're really way
out we're in deep waters here
i think you know we're trying to label
this stuff
oh i love this love this chase so